and it was something that Terry had
planned to do 2 weeks before and so um I
said to the singing telegram okay what's
the message and us I'm saying that
Karen's got her arm around me and kiss
giving me kisses and stuff like that and
he goes message is up there and so I
look up and there's a plane that's just
flying around Mr Jay's in the big
parking lot and it's Sky riding across
its wings I'm ready to jump marry me
Terry and I went just tell me she's not
here he goes she's over there and I look
and I see Terry's car and the door is
opening and Terry is wearing the wedding
dress that she was wearing in the
Masquerade video and she's halfway out
the car and sees Karen kissing me and
suddenly realizes oh my God you know all
the times I've been with Karen and Terry
slammed the door shut and I just ran
over to her car and held on to the
handle of the the car and I'm screaming
I love you I love you I'm so sorry I
love you and she just drove off with
tears in her eyes